[Music]  what are you doing that  remember that freestyle I did it the  other day  Tony trim you spell it with a double M  everything I say might be trouble live  to your sister or your grandmother it's  entertaining like The Smothers Brothers  yeah you didn't throw that away in hell  no where's some money I'm gonna make  this like the Martin shkreli boot a  gallon give me a million dollars for  this [ __ ] it's a hot bars problem no  your expectations  I look so best offer there's one of one  signed and everything signed everything  put the stamp on there I'll put the  stamp on it  damn are you all ready Stanley you  really thought this through